eris
utz vaart il est là le grand noir
le bo l'éloquent l'orateur noir le voilà
évidemment tous l'attendent et on allait
enfin le voir et tous étaient impatients
c'était aujourd'hui pour ce soir
maintenant et le voilà la noire
magistrale une souris
c'est magique on ne voit plus que lui
sa seule présence décuple vos forces
raviver vos sens et soudain l'attention
reprend on retrouve des couleurs le noir
est plus intense je sais déjà ce que
vous ressentez c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
à moi un blanc je suis james gregory
surveillants ici à la prison de robben
island cape town en afrique du sud et je
vais être son geôlier à lui nelson
mandela alors dites moi combien parmi
vous avez vu que j'étais blanc je viens
de vous conter sommairement l'histoire
de james gregory véritable afrikaner de
souche les racines solidement ancré dans
cette afrique du sud de l'apartheid
ce jour là ils rencontrent pour la
première fois nelson mandela à la prison
de robben island avec qui il restera
durant 18 de ses 27 années de prison
pendant tout ce temps ils n'auront tous
les deux une relation extraordinaire
qu'il mettra sur papier dans un livre
livres par lequel il prêtera sa plume à
nelson mandela est ainsi nuit il blanc
il deviendra son [ __ ] qui pouvait
imaginer que lui james gregory d'abord
geôliers blanc deviendrez le confident
et l'alter ego de cet immense
prisonniers noirs qui pouvait imaginer
que lui
nelson mandela symbole de la répression
violente systématique du fait de sa
couleur de peau noire puisse plus tard
embrassé à ce point la cause blanc
lui en aura fallu du temps et des mots
après tout ce temps nelson mandela
ressortira plus blanc et james gregory
beaucoup plus noir et vous combien de
temps cela vous a pris pour voir que
j'étais noir blanc noir nemo voilà donc
comment les mots peuvent changer votre
couleur de peau j'ai choisi d'illustrer
mon propos avec cette histoire car
clairement existe-t-il changement de
couleur plus éclatant que celle du blanc
en noir et vice versa j'ai pris cet
exemple parce que moi je suis convaincu
que les mots changent tout j'ai pris cet
exemple parce que moi je sais que les
mots changent votre couleur mois
les mots ont changé ma couleur si je
suis ici devant vous c'est parce que ma
propre histoire est l'exact panachage de
celle de grégory et nelson moi ma vie
est teinté de ce changement de couleur
faisant un cas pratique ensemble
ici ce soir qui pensent que je suis noir
ou quasiment tout le monde être noir ça
représente bien plus qu'une couleur
n'est ce pas on est tous un peu le noir
de quelqu'un à quelque part être blanc
aussi ça signifie davantage qu'une
couleur on a tous besoin à un moment
donné de blanchir davantage alors vous
dites que je suis noir sous métaux ce
sondage à l'épreuve des mots des
ensembles observer comment je change de
couleur grâce aux mots vous dites que je
suis noir et si moi je vous dis que je
suis d'extrême droite a tout de suite je
suis un peu moins noir
si je vous dis que j'ai grandi dans le
village de saint-antoine l'abbaye si je
vous dis que j'ai passé toute ma
scolarité dans l'établissement
notre-dame de l'espérance
si je vous dis que mon plat préféré et
le cassoulet si je vous dis que mon film
préféré est la soupe aux choux mon
acteur préféré michel galabru la musique
j'écoute en boucle
gérard lenorman si je vous dis que j'ai
remporté une médaille d'or jeux
olympiques d'hiver
[Applaudissements]
si je vous dis que je ne sais pas danser
que je maîtrise parfaitement la brasse
papillon que mon père s'appelle eugène
ma mère mathilde ma grande soeur
sébastiennais ma petite soeur yolande
alors je suis toujours aussi noir
vous voyez comment on change la couleur
de peau avec les mots vous voyez comment
en utilisant habilement les mots on
opère jusqu'à cette transformation
pigmentaire parler et vous mettez en
branle et l'imaginaire l'imaginaire
car le bon mot créé la bonne image et
une image s'est inlassablement en
couleurs moi même j'ai véritablement
pris conscience de ma couleur
en même temps que j'ai véritablement
parler à l'autre
c'était assez tôt en primaire par la
cour mes camarades me parler avait des
mots durs uniquement dû à ma différence
de pigmentation serge j'avais pas jouer
avec toi tu es noir sert des noirs tutu
ah les enfants parfois des mots en
couleurs mais pas seulement
plus tard au collège ailleurs dans mon
quartier dans ma rue partout tout autour
cette inégalité dans l'appréciation il
fallait que cela change
les mots m'ont mis sur la voie je suis
devenu rappeur et puis plus tard avocats
mes mots dans chaque rôle de ma vie sont
devenus mon metteur en scène les mots ce
pinceau qui révèle votre véritable
nature et projette la couleur qui vous
sied montré la voie vous dis-je
oui la voix on le sait depuis longtemps
celle qui porte les mots la voie à une
couleur vous avez tous en tête
un chanteur ou une chanteuse avec ce
grain penser à amy winehouse dont on
disait elle a une voix de chanteuse de
gospel de chanteuse de blues pour ne pas
dire noir oui la voie à une couleur et
les mots in limine cette voie c'est la
raison pour laquelle lorsque vous parlez
on peut tout savoir de vous votre
éducation votre quotidien
votre origine votre couleur n'avez-vous
jamais eu cette révélation lorsque vous
parlez un inconnu au téléphone
n'avez-vous jamais eu cette réflexion
alors que vous êtes en train d'appeler
cette hotline qui se trouve au bout du
monde de vous dire là à l'autre bout du
fil les noirs oui les mots et les
couleurs vont si bien ensemble que
parfois même les mots sont une couleur
rougeole jauni
je me souviens j'avais 20 ans et je
devais me faire enlever une varice et
avant l'opération le docteur me dit
monsieur monnaie c'est extraordinaire
les varices ça n'arrive jamais au jeune
très rarement aux hommes est extrêmement
peu fréquemment aux africains et je lui
dis docteur vous m'avez démasqué g je
suis une vieille femme blanche
[Applaudissements]
après tôt j'ai montré patte blanche
d'abord en étudiant le droit ensuite en
faisant du rap
dix ans plus tard retournant à la gomme
sur les bancs de la fac pour devenir
finalement avocat
et oui j'en ai vu de toutes les couleurs
je sais ce qu'est le poids des mots et
le choc des propos j'ai mis mes mots sur
papier puis sur le son j'ai monté mon
groupe
oui je fais du rap ma fille a tressé
lorsque je me suis lancé dans le rap et
qu'il fallait prendre à nom de scène
j'aurais pu vu les multiples couleurs
que j'ai à rebours et m'appelait le
caméléon mais en plus de serge m
j'ai choisi ma peau rouge et j'ai pris
le pseudo de cochise l'indien cochise
j'aimais le symbole de ces pour rouge
qui était entré en rébellion contre
l'envahisseur le colon blanc oui j'ai
fait du rap et ce fut une expérience
extraordinaire avec ma fille quatre
essais pendant 10 ans on en a vendu plus
de 300000 album disque d'or
on aura fait des tournées dans toute la
france et j'ai balader ma peau rouge
pendant dix ans dans toute la france
pour tous les quatre coins avec mes
comparses
on a vite compris que si on voulait
faire ce rap avec cette couleur des plus
agréables il fallait prendre le temps de
bien choisir nos maux de bien choisir
nos images de faire de belles rives oui
de bons mots pour de beaux textes et
donc un joli râble et voilà
l'enchaînement vertueux qui transforme
une image du rappeur et donne au rap
cette couleur on veut me stopper depuis
le temps que ça dure ça prend une salle
en pleurs ça m'attriste
j'ai l'âme en peine et mon style nos
pleurs lancre couler fait sentir les
mêmes rancoeur qu'en bas qui - des rings
comme cevital comme à coeur qui bat j'ai
peur de louper le salut je dors que d'un
seul oeil au réveil c'est l'aider rêve
s'éloigne comme neige au soleil
je sors les plus belles phases afin de
séduire
les feuilles vierges qu'elle dise eder
j'aime qui s cochise ou serge m
vous avez vu ma peau rouge
j'ai dû l'abandonner
dix ans plus tard à 30 ans pour
retourner sur les bancs de la fac
au sortir de dix années couver dans
cette espèce de star system j'en ai vu
de toutes les douleurs et toutes les
couleurs mais je me suis accroché à
cette inspiration
cette nécessité de changer encore de
couleurs je voulais êtres avocat
pourquoi avocat existe-t-il métier
qu'ils puissent plus faire changer la
couleur des gens par les mots c'est la
couleur n'est pas nécessairement lié au
bout ce sont les mots que vous utilisez
qui fixera la vôtre et moi je voulais
faire changer la couleur des autres
grâce à mes mots à moi car je suis
convaincu que changer la couleur ça
change tout posez la question à un
accusé à tort ou à raison
quand on est voué aux gémonies vous mine
sombre
on n'est pas des saints mais tous nous
cherchons à nous rapprocher d'une
conception immaculé à mon tour je vous
regarde
je sais que chacun de vous à un moment
donné de sa vie a ressenti cette
sensation de subir une différence de
traitement
simplement parce qu'il était différent
de l'autre ont trop femmes pas assez bon
trop petit bassin
que sais-je c'est ça être le noir de
l'autre
moi j'étais trop pauvres trop
banlieusards 3 patrick intro rappeur
trop noir quoi mais les mots permettent
de changer cette image que vous projetez
les mots permettent de modifier la
couleur dans les yeux de l'autre vous
pouvez le faire
moi je les fais et je suis devenu avocat
j'ai réalisé que l'avocat est monochrome
l'avocat aussi à une couleur et c'est
pas le noir je les ai compris lorsque je
passais le concours de la conférence un
concours d'éloquence assez exigeant qui
permet au sortir de trois tous basés sur
des discours vient d'élire des douze
lauréats qui seront les prestigieux
secrétaire de la conférence à vie moi je
les passais j'arrivais quatre fois au
troisième tour et pour ne pas me retenir
on m'a dit tu sais serge monnaie
la conférence est une vieille femme
traditionnelle qui a du mal à s'ouvrir
au monde mais j'ai pris le temps je me
suis accroché au mot et au bout de la
cinquième fois je n'ai obtenu
aujourd'hui je suis avocat pénaliste
avec une petite réputation
ancien secrétaire de la conférence oui
hier quand j'étais rappeur et que je
déclarais que demain je serai avocat on
me disait toi tu as oublié que tu es
noir aujourd'hui que je suis avocat
quand je rappelle que hier j'étais
rappeur on me dit toi j'ai oublié que tu
es noir avocat le temps les mots voilà
autant d'éléments qui permettent de
comprendre que l'enjeu est crucial
et quand les enjeux sont cruciaux
il faut vraiment prendre le temps moi
j'ai pris ce temps j'ai choisi mes mots
et j'ai changé ma couleur en même temps
que celle de mes clients que je blanche
et changer la couleur
ce n'est pas se trahir soi même changer
la couleur ce n'est pas usé de
stratagèmes pour tromper l'autre au
contraire c'est se révéler tel que l'on
est
s'exposer pour présenter la totalité de
vos qualités faire savoir qu'on a à
savoir faire se faire voir pour être vu
le temps nous enseigne du petit au grand
écran
n'étant pas passer du muet au parler du
noir et blanc à la couleur
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui moi je fais évoluer
ma couleur grandeur nature ma compagne
pourrait témoigner neuf mois dans la
palette maternelle à mixer les couleurs
cela donne forcément le plus beau des
tableaux ma fille on dit qu'elle est
métissée elle est comme nous tous a
semblé rassemblés par la magie des mots
la magie vous savez comment elle agit
par une formule voici la mienne
on ne choisit pas sa couleur non choisi
ses mots
ayez le bon nous et vous aurez la bonne
couleur c'est ce que je me suis employé
à faire ce soir
ge est apparue une noire j'ai été blanc
j'ai remis ma peau rouge juste avec les
mots les mots ce pinceau qui va colorer
cette planche blanche qu'on appelle le
destin moi je vous parle et je peins je
m'appelle monnaie
et je vous refais le portrait
mais les craintes il n'y aura pas
d'ombré au tableau
car ce soir je vais tous vous nous
donner la même couleur
en un mot un seul
regardez vous et vous voyez comment vous
devenez tous noirs
[Applaudissements]